mesdames messieurs chers amis je n'y ai
je n'imaginais pas il y a seulement
quelques semaines
cette rencontre en ces lieux mais la vie
politique a au moins un charme c'est
celui de son imprévisibilité mais peu
importe je suis heureux de vous
retrouver vous me suivez la vie
politique au jour le jour et partager
avec les élus politiques
une passion parfois dévorante celle que
constitue la vie politique
heureux d'avoir à mes côtés
brigitte huster guillaume larrivé annie
genevard valérie rosso debord
gérald darmanin philippe juvin et
valérie boyer dont vous connaissez
toutes les titres qui sont évidemment
importants comme le sont les types pour
chacun d'entre nous ici aux républicains
j'ai été nommé avec un objectif
prioritaire et deux objectifs
complémentaires
l'objectif principal est une évidence
faire gagner notre candidat françois
fillon le 23 avril et le 7 mai prochain
le second objectif conditions pour
réformer la france et la victoire au
législatif les 11 et 18 juin et le
troisième sera la victoire aux
sénatoriales le 29 septembre
pourtant dans toute action
il faut toujours se demander est ce re
demander quelle est notre objectif
et pourquoi il nous apparaît nécessaire
de la peindre c'est parce que la france
l'europe le monde vont mal que la france
a besoin d'un chef d'état à la hauteur
des défis qui sont devant nous le défi
de la paix mondiale
le défi d'une europe qui affronte la
crise la plus grave depuis le traité de
rome
mais d'abord le défi de la france
confronté à la situation la plus
inquiétante depuis la fin de la
quatrième république crise économique et
sociale avec un niveau de chômage
hélas jamais atteints d
industrialisation chaque jour plus
angoissante crise sécuritaire avec la
menace terroriste permanente crise
financière avec des déficits
chaque année renouvelé une dette qui
devient de plus en plus inquiétante des
prélèvements publics records une crise
agricole une crise morale et une crise
politique enfin avec cette perte
inquiétante de confiance des citoyens
envers leurs élus les élus de la
démocratie avec cette montée puissante
du vote populiste et des extrêmes avec
un éclatement de pans entiers du paysage
politique pour le moment à gauche dans
cet environnement
chaque jour plus morcelé par les
divisions et des stratégies
individuelles devant les menaces qui
pèsent sur l'avenir de notre pays
les républicains apporteront toute leur
énergie pour défendre les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres pour défendre les
réformes dans lesquelles nous croyons et
notre candidat qui les porte devant les
français nous le ferons face à cette
gauche explosé après les cinq années du
quinquennat de françois hollande
un président élu sur le déni de la crise
sur des promesses intenables ou
mensongère
un président qui prétend maintenant
avoir réglé tous les problèmes reconnaît
que le monde est dangereux mais en même
temps déclare abandonné la france a son
destin en refusant pour la première fois
sous la vème république de se soumettre
au jugement des français
nous le ferons face à une extrême droite
dont le projet s'apparente chaque jour
un peu plus
un programme commun économique social et
européen commun entre le front national
et l'excès l'extrême gauche nous le
ferons face à monsieur macron fils
parricide de françois hollande
homme de gauche qui s'en défend qui doit
tout à françois hollande dont il a été
l'instigateur zélé de la castastrophique
politiques économiques et fiscales dont
il a été le ministre de l'économie
un ministre dont les des gaz industriels
économiques sociaux sont et serait
énorme
s'ils n'étaient pas pris en compte et
corrigé doute nous dénonçons ce n'est
qu'une ce qui n'est qu'une vaste tout
dénonçons ce qui n'est qu'une vaste
opération de marketing électoral une
véritable escroquerie politique conduite
par un pur produit de ce qu'il prétend
lui même dénoncé françois fillon a gagné
très largement la primaire de la droite
et du centre
cette victoire n'était pas prévu par les
sondeurs et les observateurs
mais la primaire n'est qu'une étape sur
le chemin difficile long de l'élection
présidentielle elle même est ici nous en
sommes bien conscients pour faire gagner
françois fillon aux républicains nous
nous sommes rassemblés
la direction a réservé une place à des
proches de chacun des candidats à la
primaire
le rassemblement l'unité pour défendre
notre candidat et son projet seront
total
il n'y aura pas de place pour les états
d'âme ou les stratégies personnelles
l'enjeu est trop important l'enjeu est
crucial crucial il est l'avenir de la
france et des français
le projet de françois fillon est
audacieux il entend interrompre une
dérive mortifère pour notre pays celle
de la facilité alors que la france a
tous les atouts pour retrouver sa place
dans le monde et redonner aux français
leur niveau de vie pour aujourd'hui et
pour demain
persister sur la même voie celle des
déficits perpétuelle d'une dette de plus
en plus abyssal ne pourrait conduire
comme toutes les graves crises
financières que vers une catastrophe
sociale une catastrophe politique
voilà pourquoi nous formulons des voeux
de réussite pour notre pays
en conduisant notre candidat à la
victoire au printemps prochain mais en
attendant est d'abord je formule pour
chacun et chacune d'entre vous des voeux
de santé et de bonheur et je formule
aussi des voeux pour un avenir meilleur
pour la presse une presse qui
travaillent dans des conditions de plus
en plus difficile rendant son avenir
incertain
je formule pour la presse des voeux d'un
horizon qui s'éclaire bonne année à tous